oh  my goodness oh my goodness  how are you doing girl oh you know i was  on the way home it was in the area i  just wanted to come say  hello that's it that is all have a nice  night so where are you going girl you  can't leave without coming inside  oh no i wouldn't want to be an intrusion  i just wanted to say hello goodbye there  is a seat  in this house with your name on it girl  no no no no no no  no no no i can't i didn't have money for  the bus  i'm a mess from the 50-mile wall oh  quite  must yeah be so difficult girl  you're right i am being difficult aren't  i  your life is better without me coming in  trust me so there i go  okay girl listen everything is irony man  we're good friends  all right of course you know you can  smell that girl you know you smell like  a girl  you know you're smelling the fried  dumplings the aqui in the salt fish girl  it was come over i should have here  that's it sue i'm formally inviting you  into my home now come inside  you